why do you have a love for writing
female protagonists you know
I I really just have to attribute that
to
growing up with
strong women in my life
it's my mother my stepmother my sisters
uh cousins
and in friends you know I've always been
surrounded by
by strong women
and women who I don't think I don't
think that their stories have been told
and it's it's really interesting because
I sometimes I sometimes struggle with
this
that should I be the one to tell these
stories because I'm a man
but um I think I think back to a
conversation I had with a friend and she
really wowed me when she said this
and
what she said was she was just like you
like women
and I'm just like well
yeah you know I'm I'm a straight guy I
like women she's just like no
I don't mean like in a romantic sense or
in a sexual sense I mean you like women
you pay attention you know you're uh
like empathetic like you really truly
care about women
and when she said that you know like I
said like it really stuck with me and I
thought back to
like the books that I've written the
scripts that I've written and how
I've treated my female characters and
and I've tried my best to yeah yeah tell
the stories of these women uh
um and try to uplift these characters so
that
should anything ever be made whoever
sees this perhaps they'll see themselves
in that character and they'll feel you
know they'll get that message they'll
you know they'll feel empowered they'll
feel uplifted
so
it's it's really just due to the women
in my life I mean I've just had amazing
women in my life and they inspire me
they they truly do inspire me
let's see some of you have brought some
of your books with you here yeah yeah
I'm just because I read a little bit
about them on Amazon and each one had an
interesting story I was just wondering
if you could hold it up and just quickly
tell us sure
so
this is guest list this is my first book
and it tells the story of a young woman
uh young woman uh named Juliet who moves
from Miami to New York when she gets to
New York she gets caught up in the whole
nightlife scene meets a popular party
promoter and Sparks Fly
okay
um
yeah the reception to this book was was
really good I was honestly I was worried
because of what we were talking about
you know I was worried about how people
would um respond to the depiction of
Juliet
um you know I wondered if this was the
story that I should tell because I was
telling it from a young woman's point of
view but
apparently I you know people responded
uh the voice was authentic and so
I'm really happy with it I'm really
happy with it it's a really cool cover
too I like that thank you thank you it
was actually uh designed by um very
talented friend of mine uh Sheena
Michelle Reese uh civilized media she
she designed this is actually the second
cover
for guest list the initial cover was in
a nightclub and had the disco ball and
everything but I wanted Juliet to be on
the cover and so
what were you afraid of with that
character that the audience May either
think you weren't the right person to
write it or whatever it was well again
you know just
I'm a man writing you know uh about a
young woman in writing you know
through her point of view
and
you know it's a romance and and the book
goes certain places you know especially
like sexually and and I just
I I was worried that it would come off
as inauthentic
um I was worried that
that maybe uh
I know I've seen gripes of like male
writers you know writing uh their
fantasy
you know writing and oh gosh there was a
hilarious example I saw on Twitter where
it was
I don't know something like a woman's
lips were
as big as I don't know biggest balloons
or you know it's just something so odd
that clearly the author thought was uh
um alluring
and that everyone else is just like this
is terrible this is horrible men stop
writing women like this and so that's
what I was you know one of the things I
was afraid of I was afraid that
um
you know people would think that you
know I'm just writing my fantasy
um
that I may be objectifying women in some
way and that clearly wasn't my intent
you know I just this is a story that I
felt needed to be told sure sure and
let's see some of the other ones you got
there
this is Manhattan sweetheart nice
um I forgive me I forget the uh
illustrator's name but she's like a
fashion illustrator a Russian fashion
illustrator and she gave me so many
different uh options for the cover
um but it's great
um but Manhattan sweetheart
um is about
um it's actually about a young man who
pursues a young woman
and um you know he's trying his best
she's essentially revealed uh to be a
call girl
and he just comes to realize you know he
can't compete with the world that she's
in and the things that she wants and
what she's after
um again this was another book that you
know I was worried about how people
would respond what people would think
but I wasn't trying to you know in any
way like
uh objectify or or disrespect you know
or anything like that it was just a
story that I wanted to tell
and um it's also
um
inspired by Breakfast at Tiffany's uh I
love Breakfast at Tiffany's both the
book and the film
and this is just kind of like my spin on
Breakfast at Tiffany's it was just
something that I I felt I needed to to
write at the time
do you do you almost hear the critics in
your head and then you counteract them
no no okay I don't think about I don't
think about criticism until after the
work is done
and not even after the work is done but
after the work is done and it's out
there
you know I didn't have any um
any kind of like thoughts you know in
writing Manhattan sweetheart or guest
list until they were published and they
were out in the world and then it was
just like um wait a minute
you know should I have done that was was
that you know the right story was that
should I have included maybe like that
plot point or whatever but
but yeah you know apparently I'm I'm
okay that's good yeah and we have one
more there I do
I mentioned earlier I grew up in the
neighborhood called orange mound in
Memphis Tennessee
this is orangebound the novel oh wow
okay
um very cool thank you this was
um
young Earl Gray did the cover she's an
Australian artist and I just loved her
style and she was able to to create this
it's supposed to kinda evoke black
exploitation
um I don't know that it does but but
it's also got a comic bookie uh quality
that I love and you know the story is
it's it's a thriller it's you know it's
got action elements and everything but
it's also very much like exaggerated
like a comic book would be so I think
that the cover really works for for the
for the story
um and it tells the tale of
um this is actually another male
protagonist it tells the tale of a ant
who's
um trying to leave the drug dealing game
behind
and he gets wrapped up uh in a romantic
entanglement with a hair stylist named
Tuffy
um but then he suspects that when Tuffy
disappears he suspects that Tuffy has
stolen his money
and a lot of you know other elements
come together you know the real bad guys
come coming to play and
um I do have
Gigi Garcia she's like very prominent on
the cover she's like the main enforcer
for the bad guys and uh you know she's
uh
she's a she's a strong female character
but she's also very lethal
um I've had um people who've read this
book I've had a lot of them comment on
Gigi like they love her because of uh
you know her character she's very much
chaotic evil
[Laughter]
what advice do you have for writing
female protagonists once again it's it's
it's it's paying attention
um I think that
a large reason why I'm able to write
female protagonists I guess as well as I
do is because I really have paid
attention to the women in my life I pay
attention to the women around me
um you know I pay attention to you know
the situations that they may find
themselves in and how they respond or
how
um they would have liked to have
responded you know it's it's really just
all about paying attention and and and
figuring out how to
how to take what you've seen and and
give give that to your characters
sure and maybe you know when you talked
about
um so many male writers possibly or
perceived as writing like this fantasy
but if you're writing where the women
have like these fears and doubts and
insecurities and things I don't know
where that plays into a fantasy that
sounds like a real person I mean yeah
yeah yeah you know I I'm I'm not yeah
that's the thing I'm not coming at my
female characters you know from from
that fantasy standpoint you know like
I'm not
like I am creating a person you know and
telling that person's story and you've
got to you've got to
really know that person inside now you
know their hopes their fears you know
how they would react in a certain
situation like who they are you really
have to know who your character is and I
think that if you're able to do that you
can avoid
making uh making those types of mistakes
sure and the reverse could be said for
women writing men that if you're just
writing this one-dimensional stud hero
that's just there's they never not they
never have any doubt I mean that that
doesn't seem real either right so you
know the same could be said because you
know there's a lot of of course
criticism well how can we write someone
that we don't really that we aren't
really in that situation well
I mean we we've we've met people and we
can pick up on things and yeah I don't
feel like we should be barred from
writing or things that aren't in our
gender or neighborhood or whatever right
exactly what challenges do you face when
writing female protagonists
it's it would
really be just like the Small Things
[Laughter]
um
you know just for example
um gosh
I feel like I'm gonna say something
horrible here but oh that's okay we can
take it out
you know while I'm all about you know
paying attention and and and looking at
the details I mean there are some things
I just don't know you know for example
um Tuffy who's a hair stylist
um I grew up around women who were you
know in that world you know who were
hair stylists my stepmother owned a
beauty salon
but I am not a hair stylist and so it's
just like you know um
small small details about say like
women's hair you know I want to know am
I getting this right you know like it
sounds crazy silly but those are those
are the challenges you know uh um just
kind of like the minutia of of of of
women's life you know I'm not a woman so
I wouldn't know that so that's what's
difficult and that's what you know those
are the questions I would ask in writing
it's just like okay I have you know
um this female character doing this
saying this pondering this am I getting
it right you know is this is this
accurate you know I will ask for
feedback on that and
based on that apply that you know make
whatever changes are necessary just to
go back to your point you know we
we're all people we all have similar
experiences uh uh and feelings you know
regardless of where we may have grown up
or or or or
you know where we work or who we
interact with
I don't think it's it's difficult to
write female characters
difficult to write women because
women are human you know it's and and
it's really just kind of applying like
that same Humanity
that I would to a male character it's
like it's not difficult what's there's a
quote
um from Jack Nicholson and and As Good
As It Gets where someone asks you know
how do you write females
hey what does he say he says I take away
accountability I think of a man or
something yeah and I take away
accountability account I don't know I
always think about that quote I'm it's
just like so horrible so horrible but um
but it works for his character it works
for his character definitely
but yeah when it comes to crafting
female characters you know it's really
it's not like you know it's thinking
about them as a human as a person you
know we all go through it we all
you know have similar stuff going on so
it's
the depth you know that's not difficult
it's like I said it's just like the kind
of maybe superficial stuff
I swear and one thing that I love
Margaret Atwood says about female
characters is that she doesn't make them
all sweetness and light because all you
know human beings have a range of
emotions in them even even the best ones
so she gives them good qualities as well
as the bad so I think that's another
thing that she said was she saw that you
know sometimes women didn't have these
depths to them they weren't dark enough
you know in terms of certain thoughts
that you know
weren't always good you know I think she
said some woman stood up in the audience
said we're tired of being painted as
good all the time you know and and you
know I'm sure in this beauty shop you
know people can fight in hair stylists
and there's all sorts of interesting
stuff in there oh yeah yeah to be
continued what do you hate seeing in
female characters
I
I hate seeing like the kind of
one-dimensional
Damsel in Distress are are you know uh
it's kind of like you know dainty you
know women have
women have range you know women you know
have dark as well as light uh you know
as you mentioned
in my book orange Mound the character of
Gigi Garcia uh I don't think that I ever
I've ever seen a female character like
this like in film or literature I could
I take that back I take that back
um
there's a book called I think heartsick
and the antagonist is essentially like a
female Hannibal Lecter
um Gretchen Gretchen something I can't
remember but you know reading a
character you know like that singing
character like that in that book you
wouldn't expect you know we've we've
never seen anything like that and I
tried to do something like that with my
character Gigi Garcia you know I think
that's probably why a lot of people
responded to this character because she
is strong you know she's you know
physically strong you know she takes on
the guys
um but she's you know super intelligent
you know I wanted to create a formidable
villain and I don't think that that you
know had really been seen
um and so and and so that's the thing
you know I
as you mentioned like women have range
uh and
I hate seeing female characters that
don't take full advantage of that
that's my roundabout way of of getting
there saying that is that I I don't like
when you know these female characters
are certainly capable of
showing and expressing so much more than
the writer has allowed them to
and they get stuck in
in a role that honestly serves a plot
instead of the other way around